Musique intense
-Elle est redevenue
le champ de bataille incontournable
du débat politique.
Applaudissements
-Ici, c'est l'Assemblée nationale !
Ce sont les députés
qui font la loi !
-Votes serrés,
oppositions frontales,
alliances incertaines...
Depuis un an maintenant,
l'Assemblée nationale
concentre à nouveau l'attention.
-On ne va pas
dans une salle de cinéma
où il y a pas de film,
là, ils passent un film,
donc les Français s'y intéressent.
-Contraints à une majorité relative
par les électeurs,
les députés de la coalition
présidentielle
et le gouvernement naviguent
en eaux troubles dans l'hémicycle.
-Tout le monde
nous prédisait le blocage absolu
et disait qu'avec la configuration
de l'Assemblée,
on ne pourrait pas gouverner.
-Gouverner
vaille que vaille,
parfois dans la tempête.
-Le niveau de tension
qu'on acquiert ce jour-là
me paraît assez inédit.
-...mais comparaison
n'est pas raison.
-Comment le gouvernement parvient-il
à faire voter
ses projets de loi ?
-Vous interrogez
sur une mesure de régulation.
-Quand et pourquoi décide-t-il
de passer en force ?
-...aussi, sur le fondement
de l'article 49,
alinéa 3 de la Constitution,
j'engage la responsabilité...
-Et à quel prix ?
-L'Assemblée
ne peut pas continuer
quatre années supplémentaires
comme cela.
C'est impossible.
-Retour sur une année parlementaire
mouvementée où la majorité a marché
en permanence
sur un fil.
-Et voilà, le chiffre tombe
dans une seconde, maintenant.
Il est 20h, vous découvrez
le visage de la nouvelle
Assemblée nationale,
les estimations en nombre de sièges.
Et c'est Ensemble qui arrive en tête
avec 224 sièges.
On est très loin
de la majorité absolue
de 289 sièges.
-C'est un tremblement de terre.
-C'est la plus petite
majorité relative
qu'on ait trouvée
sous la Ve République.
C'est quelque chose...
-Le nouvel hémicycle
qui s'affiche sur les écrans
le 19 juin 2022 est inédit.
Alors même
qu'Emmanuel Macron vient d'être
réélu président de la République,
ces résultats
sont pour sa majorité
un revers cinglant et inattendu.
Les rapports de forces
dans l'hémicycle sont chamboulés.
-On a beaucoup de sièges
qui vont séparer
la majorité relative
de la majorité absolue,
et surtout, une grande difficulté
à faire des alliances.
-Si la majorité présidentielle
exclut d'emblée de travailler
avec le Rassemblement national
et la France Insoumise,
elle va en revanche devoir jouer
l'ouverture avec les autres groupes.
L'enjeu : trouver des partenaires
texte par texte.
-Vous avez
des grandes coalitions
qui sont parfois composées
de gens qui se combattent,
pendant la période électorale,
mais qui travaillent ensuite
pour que le gouvernement produise
et fasse avancer le pays,
comme en Allemagne.
Je vois pas en quoi cela
est choquant.
Peut-être que notre culture
politique nous a habitués
et peut-être que les Français
nous ont
contraints à devoir faire avec,
comme ils avaient contraint
des présidents de la République
à vivre une cohabitation.
-C'est sûr que c'est un exercice
assez inédit.
En fait, souvent,
les partis d'opposition
aiment bien rester confortablement
dans l'opposition
quand ils y sont et dire
qu'ils sont contre tout.
Si on est tous dans cette logique,
il se passera pas grand-chose.
-Le 6 juillet, la nouvelle
présidente de l'Assemblée,
Yaël Braun-Pivet,
donne le véritable coup d'envoi
de la 16e mandature.
Brouhaha
-La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
-C'est le jour du discours
de politique générale
d'Elisabeth Borne,
mais quelques semaines plus tôt,
c'était son baptême du feu
dans l'arène parlementaire.
-Mesdames et messieurs
les députés...
-Les Français
font véritablement
sa connaissance à ce moment-là,
parce que tous les projecteurs,
déjà, sont beaucoup plus braqués
sur l'Assemblée nationale,
et à ce moment-là, elle fait
un discours fort, clair...
-Les Français nous demandent
de nous parler plus,
de nous parler mieux,
je veux qu'ensemble,
nous redonnions un sens
et une vertu au mot "compromis",
depuis trop longtemps oublié
dans notre vie politique.
Acclamations
et applaudissements
...
Musique intense
-Faute de majorité dans l'hémicycle,
la Première ministre renonce
à solliciter
un vote de confiance.
En réaction, les groupes
de la NUPES déposent
une motion de censure pour faire
déjà tomber le gouvernement.
...
A gauche, le ton est donné.
-Dans toute grande démocratie
du monde,
la Première ministre demande
la confiance au Parlement,
et là, elle s'en passe.
En quelque sorte,
la confiance que lui accorderait
le président de la République
suffirait pour que ce gouvernement
puisse mener son action.
Nous ne sommes pas d'accord.
-Pour passer,
une motion doit être votée
par la moitié des députés plus un.
Les seuls élus de la NUPES
ne suffisent pas
pour atteindre ce seuil.
C'est dans ce contexte
déjà éruptif
que l'Assemblée nationale
va se réunir
en session extraordinaire
à l'été 2022.
Les deux premiers textes
qui arrivent dans l'hémicycle
portent sur la gestion
de la crise sanitaire
et une aide exceptionnelle
au pouvoir d'achat.
-Les textes
restent relativement consensuels.
Ils sont pensés comme ça.
On peut discuter sur les milliards
qu'on va redistribuer,
mais c'est plus facile
de redistribuer des milliards
que d'en enlever.
-Des textes consensuels
sur le papier,
mais dans l'hémicycle,
c'est une autre affaire.
-Il va falloir s'habituer
à des débats vifs
dans cette assemblée,
et peut-être
que ça vous sortira un peu
de votre ronron néolibéral.
-Le projet de pouvoir d'achat
du gouvernement,
il est nullissime.
On va pas s'en cacher,
-Cette assemblée de Playmobil
qui ne répond qu'aux injonctions
de l'exécutif,
elle est fini.
-Ce que j'en retiens,
c'est quand même un décor
qui est planté
qui me paraît être durable,
c'est celui
d'une opposition forte...
d'une confrontation
sans merci.
-Pour : 96.
Contre : 161.
L'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté.
-Mise à mal dans l'hémicycle,
la majorité
est pour la première fois
battue
par les oppositions
lors d'un vote important.
Il concerne un article
du projet de loi sanitaire.
-Cet applaudissement
un peu commun
pour montrer que le gouvernement
ne peut pas tout est quelque chose
qui va donner le ton
de cette année parlementaire :
la majorité est sur le gril.
On a le sentiment
que l'opposition a plus
comme objectif de défaire
ce que fait la majorité
que parfois, de lancer
des propositions alternatives.
-L'avis est défavorable.
-Poussés déjà
dans leurs retranchements,
le gouvernement et la majorité
l'emportent
au moment des votes définitifs
sur ces deux textes.
-C'est un soulagement,
étant donné
que pour la majorité,
l'idée qu'on peut gouverner
texte par texte devient à présent
relativement crédible.
Mais soyons clairs :
personne n'est dupe.
Gouverner comme ça
sur ce type de textes
est déjà relativement compliqué.
En tout cas, ça amène
à des tensions parlementaires.
Que va-t-il advenir
quand les textes
seront plus compliqués ?
-L'automne puis le reste
de l'année parlementaire
vont confirmer
la tendance de l'été.
-L'Assemblée nationale a adopté.
Cris de protestation
-Le projet de loi est adopté.
-L'Assemblée nationale
a adopté.
-Tous les projets de loi
soumis au vote sont adoptés
par les députés
avec des alliances différentes
selon les textes.
Ils portent sur la sécurité,
les énergies renouvelables,
le nucléaire ou encore
la réforme
du marché du travail.
Les détails des votes montrent
que le premier allié de la majorité
est le groupe Les Républicains.
Il a voté pour dans 64 % des votes
sur des projets de loi.
-On a avancé
sur l'assurance-chômage,
on a avancé sur le nucléaire,
on a voté effectivement
pas mal de textes.
Nous, on fait en sorte,
effectivement,
de les aiguiller
plutôt vers la droite.
-La proximité entre LR
et le gouvernement est flagrante,
et ils l'ont montré
de manière récurrente
depuis un an, au point
que je pense qu'ils ont perdu
tout crédit
auprès des Français
qui sont opposés au gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron.
-Deuxième partenaire de la majorité
dans l'hémicycle,
le groupe centriste LIOT,
avec 57 % de votes favorables
sur les projets de loi.
Vient ensuite
le Rassemblement national
avec 38 %,
un chiffre qui peut surprendre
venant d'un groupe
en opposition frontale
au gouvernement.
-Nos électeurs nous envoient
défendre un certain nombre
de choses, si on leur dit
qu'on vote pas
parce que le gouvernement
le propose,
ils vont nous dire
qu'on rompt notre mandat.
Il y a un certain nombre de textes
comme ceux-là
qui nous apparaissent
évidemment
très largement améliorables,
mais qui vont plutôt
dans le sens de l'intérêt général,
donc nous les votons.
-C'est une stratégie politique.
Ils ne peuvent plus apparaître
comme des opposants claniques.
Ils doivent montrer
qu'ils deviennent
un parti du gouvernement.
Après, ils votent ou pas,
je cherche pas leurs voix.
J'ai pas besoin de leurs voix.
Et les différents textes,
même sans leurs voix,
auraient été adoptés.
-Madame la présidente...
-Les alliances sont beaucoup plus
difficiles avec la NUPES.
Les socialistes
n'ont voté favorablement
que sur 14 %
des projets de loi.
Les écologistes
et la France Insoumise, eux,
n'ont jamais rien voté.
...
-Nous n'allons pas voter
des textes
avec lesquels nous sommes
en désaccord, des textes qui sont
les mêmes recettes qui mènent
aux mêmes échecs.
Et nous sommes encore une fois
les opposants d'Emmanuel Macron.
La question n'est pas si nous devons
faire des ouvertures.
-La NUPES, ce sont les otages
de la France Insoumise,
de M. Mélenchon.
Donc voilà, ils sont un peu tenus,
même s'ils essaient d'en sortir
par le joug de cette alliance
électorale.
...
Ces votes gagnés
donnent l'impression
d'un gouvernement souverain
à l'Assemblée.
Mais la réalité
est bien plus nuancée.
Ces alliances sont fragiles,
et pour certains textes,
pas des moindres, le gouvernement
a choisi de ne pas solliciter
le vote des députés.
Il a préféré
passer en force.
...
10 octobre 2022, Yaël Braun-Pivet
ouvre l'examen
en séance publique
du budget 2023.
-L'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion
du projet de loi de programmation...
-Très vite, il apparaît clairement
que le gouvernement
ne trouvera pas
de majorité,
cette fois-ci.
-C'est vous qui avez tort !
Ce ne sont pas l'intégralité
des oppositions qui ont tort !
-Les Français ne sont pas cons.
Vous auriez tort
de les prendre comme tels.
-Une coalition
de l'irresponsabilité
a envoyé l'image d'un pays...
qui est incapable
de se fixer comme objectif
de maîtriser
sa dépense publique.
-Il est de tradition,
en politique, que les oppositions
votent systématiquement
contre un budget.
-Moi, j'ai souvenir
d'un vieil enseignement
d'un vieux briscard
de la politique locale
qui disait : "Dans l'opposition,
tu ne votes pas le budget."
Ca se retranscrit
au niveau national.
C'est comme ça.
Pas d'abstention, contre.
-Les oppositions sont parfaitement
dans leur rôle en refusant
de s'affilier à un budget,
puisque le budget,
c'est votre manière
de faire de la politique
et de dépenser
pour financer celle-ci.
Donc c'est très symbolique.
-Le 19 octobre, Elisabeth Borne
s'avance donc à la tribune
pour annoncer le premier recours
au 49-3
de la mandature.
...
-Sur le fondement
de l'article 48, alinéa 3,
de la Constitution,
j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement
pour la première partie
du projet de loi de finances
pour 2023.
Applaudissements
-Concrètement, le gouvernement
fait passer le texte sans vote
en engageant
sa responsabilité,
mais cette procédure
l'expose à une motion
de censure des oppositions.
La NUPES
en dépose une immédiatement,
et surprise, le groupe
Rassemblement national
va la voter.
-...mes chers collègues.
Parce que seul l'intérêt national
guide ses paroles et ses actes,
le groupe que j'ai l'honneur
de présider
votera également
la motion de censure
présentée en des termes acceptables
de l'autre côté de l'hémicycle.
Applaudissements
Une motion de censure,
c'est pas une adhésion
au groupe qui la dépose.
Une motion de censure,
c'est clairement :
le gouvernement mérite-t-il,
sur ce texte, et compte tenu
de son comportement,
d'être censuré ?
Si la réponse est oui,
quelle que soit la personne
qui dépose la motion,
on la vote, c'est simple.
-Je vais être honnête avec vous,
j'ai été...
pas amusé, mais j'ai souri,
lorsque j'ai vu les têtes
des députés de la NUPES
au moment où Marine Le Pen
a annoncé qu'elle allait
la voter.
Voilà.
-Non, ça ne nous met pas
mal à l'aise.
Je ne vais pas demander
à mes députés de s'allonger
sur les boutons de vote
des députés RN.
Les députés RN votent
comme ils le souhaitent.
Nous n'avons rien à voir
avec ces gens.
Nous combattons fermement
l'extrême droite,
mais ensuite, chacun est libre
de son vote.
-L'addition des voix
de la NUPES et du RN
ne suffit pas pour atteindre
la majorité.
La motion est rejetée.
Au total, l'article 49-3
est utilisé à 10 reprises
pour faire passer
l'ensemble du budget.
Ces passages en force répétés
ont déjà échauffé les esprits
quand arrive en séance
le texte majeur
de cette année parlementaire,
la réforme
des retraites.
-Madame la présidente.
-Le 6 février, les débats s'ouvrent
dans un hémicycle survolté.
-Vous n'avez pas
à frapper les pupitres.
La parole
est au gouvernement.
-Des engagements...
-On n'est pas dans un amphi
ni dans une manif !
On est dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale !
Applaudissements et huées
...
-Nous y sommes.
-Pour cet examen,
le gouvernement a décidé
de recourir
à une procédure accélérée.
Les députés ont 20 jours
pour débattre du texte.
C'est l'article 47-1
de la Constitution.
Son utilisation
n'est pas du goût
des oppositions.
-Avoir deux semaines
de discussions
sur un texte qui va changer la vie
de millions de Français
et même de générations à venir,
c'est inadmissible.
Je le dis,
c'est la première fois
que le 47-1 est utilisé.
Ca peut être un précédent dangereux.
-Le gouvernement a en réalité
une seule exigence,
c'est l'urgence, d'aller vite
et avec des débats très courts.
-Ca permet aussi d'avoir des débats
qui vont pas s'emboliser
pendant des mois et des mois,
mais qui vont, en tout cas,
c'est ce qu'on espérait,
non seulement durer moins longtemps,
mais surtout être plus fructueux,
utiles et sereins.
C'est pas ce qui s'est passé.
-"Sereins",
ce n'est effectivement pas
l'adjectif qui convient
pour qualifier les débats.
-Vous faites pitié.
Voilà le sentiment
que vous m'inspirez.
-Ce ne sont pas les mots
d'une Première ministre,
ce sont les mots d'un bourreau.
-La réforme ou la faillite.
C'est ça la réalité
de notre système aujourd'hui.
-Entre 2017 et 2019,
c'est 33 %
d'accidents du travail
causant la mort en plus.
Et vous avez la responsabilité
de ces choix politiques.
Vous êtes un imposteur
et un assassin.
-Cette intervention
du député Aurélien Saintoul
lui vaudra un rappel à l'ordre,
symbole de débats
d'une extrême tension.
-POUR LES RETRAITES,
LES SALAIRES ET L'EMPLOI !
-Dans toute la France,
les manifestations
s'enchaînent
à l'appel des syndicats,
et les débats s'enlisent
dans l'hémicycle.
20 000 amendements
sont déposés,
dont 13 000 par les députés
France insoumise, qui refusent
la logique d'urgence
du gouvernement.
-Vos amendements
sont inutiles, et votre comportement
ne sert à rien.
-Les jours passent, le texte
n'arrivera jamais jusqu'au vote
lors de son examen à l'Assemblée.
Même l'article 7,
qui prévoyait le report de l'âge
de départ à 64 ans,
ne sera jamais étudié.
-Monsieur le ministre,
vous avez la parole.
-Au 20e jour,
Olivier Dussopt
siffle la fin des débats
dans une ambiance électrique.
-C'est donc dans le respect
de la Constitution que nos débats
doivent désormais prendre fin.
Ce délai s'achève ce soir.
Les 20 500 amendements
déposés par la NUPES auront empêché
notre Assemblée d'achever
l'examen du texte.
Députés Insoumis,
vous m'avez insulté 15 jours.
Vous chantez,
mais vous m'avez insulté.
Personne n'a craqué.
Personne n'a craqué
et nous sommes là devant vous,
pour la réforme.
Brouhaha intense
-Je vous remercie.
-Cette semaine
de discussion
de la réforme des retraites,
dans les sondages d'opinion,
c'est la semaine
où l'Assemblée nationale a eu
la plus mauvaise image.
-Ca a été un débat très mauvais
qui a laissé un goût amer
en travers de la gorge
de la majorité des députés.
-Le texte part alors au Sénat,
où il est voté.
Il doit revenir
une dernière fois
à l'Assemblée
pour une adoption définitive.
Nous sommes le 16 mars 2023
et le vote prévu ce jour-là
est le moment le plus attendu
de l'année parlementaire.
Le gouvernement va-t-il laisser
les députés voter
ou dégainera-t-il
à nouveau le 49-3 ?
-A l'Elysée,
on s'est vu trois fois
avec le président de la République
et je suis persuadée
que sa conviction à lui,
sa force de caractère,
c'est qu'évidemment
il veut aller au vote et il veut
que chacun se prononce,
en son âme et conscience.
-Sous la Ve République,
il n'y a jamais eu autant
de réunions élyséennes.
Il y a cette phrase
de Bruno Retailleau
du choix entre la grosse Bertha
et la roulette russe.
Le gouvernement est entre 2 écueils
qui ne lui conviennent pas
et il y a ce moment du comptage.
Je pense que les 48 dernières heures
ont été consacrées au comptage.
-Je fais passer le message
sur l'état des forces
dans mon groupe,
qu'il y a environ, de mémoire,
35 députés qui sont prêts
à voter ce texte
et qu'une vingtaine
sont plutôt contre.
-Le président a voulu sonder
tous les groupes parlementaires.
Moi, en ce qui me concerne,
j'ai assez rapidement considéré
qu'il n'y aurait pas
une majorité
pour le texte tel quel.
Ensuite,
il y a eu une réflexion,
qui s'est jouée aussi
entre les deux têtes de l'exécutif,
et nous avons appris
que le 49.3 allait être utilisé.
Musique de tension
-Avec 10 minutes de retard
sur l'horaire d'ouverture
de la séance,
Elisabeth Borne arrive à l'Assemblée
pour vivre, sans doute,
le moment le plus éprouvant
de sa carrière politique.
Applaudissements et huées
...
-L'ETENDARD SANGLANT EST LEVE
-Dans un hémicycle
chauffé à blanc,
les cris et les chants
de l'opposition couvrent sa voix.
-QU'UN SANG IMPUR
ABREUVE NOS SILLONS
-Ca a été
un moment extrêmement violent.
Je n'ai pas entendu
un traître mot
de ce que la Première ministre a dit
en montant à la tribune.
Il y avait
un tel niveau sonore,
il y avait un tel niveau
de hurlements, de débordements
et d'indignité dans cet hémicycle
que nous n'avons rien entendu.
Ca a été une grande épreuve,
d'abord pour elle,
et la majorité fait bloc.
On ne le lâche pas,
car on ne peut pas
ne pas être solidaire,
malgré tout,
de la décision qui est prise.
-Ca a fait le tour du monde
et des médias internationaux,
cette Marseillaise
que nous chantons
avec ces panneaux "Démocratie",
qui marquent le fait
qu'on est en train
de passer à un seuil
où finalement,
le Parlement ne compte pas,
la rue ne compte pas
et les syndicats non plus.
Bref, en quelque sorte,
il n'existe que le président,
isolé et seul,
qui fait un énième acte
d'autoritarisme que nous refusons.
-Dans les heures qui suivent,
c'est cette fois
le groupe centriste LIOT
qui dépose
une motion de censure,
que la NUPES
et le RN soutiennent.
Les Républicains,
avec qui l'exécutif
avait pourtant conclu un accord,
sont très divisés
sur ce texte.
Le gouvernement ne semble plus tenir
qu'à un fil.
Musique énigmatique
Résultat du vote :
la motion échoue
à 9 voix près.
9 députés, voilà ce qui a manqué
pour faire chuter le gouvernement.
-"Le coup passa si près,
que le chapeau tomba." Victor Hugo.
Ca arrive en politique.
Le chapeau tombe,
pas le gouvernement.
-Si l'exécutif est pressé
de tourner
la page des retraites,
les oppositions ne veulent pas
en rester là.
Le groupe LIOT dépose
une proposition de loi
pour revenir
sur le report
de l'âge de départ.
Il est soutenu
par la NUPES et le RN.
La bataille des retraites
vire à la guérilla parlementaire.
-Cette proposition de loi
d'abrogation d'un texte
qui vient d'être voté,
déjà, c'est un inédit
sous la Ve République.
Il y a concurrence
entre Assemblée et gouvernement.
Evidemment, cette proposition
n'a pas d'avenir législatif.
La seule chose qui compte,
c'est le symbole.
Ca prouve bien
que les oppositions
ne digèrent pas, à mon avis,
peut être même bien plus
une certaine manière
d'avoir traité le Parlement
pendant cette réforme
des retraites
que la réforme des retraites.
-On peut aussi supprimer
le Parlement.
Puisqu'ils ont
une majorité relative,
faisons plus simple.
L'Assemblée n'est plus
une chambre d'enregistrement.
-Ils savent que le dispositif
ne passera jamais.
Qu'on veuille convoquer
l'Assemblée nationale
pour faire
un coup politique,
un coup politique
qui peut être susceptible
de mettre le désordre
dans le pays,
je trouve ça assez...
Assez glaçant.
Musique de tension
-Le jour de l'examen,
Yaël Braun-Pivet déclare
la proposition de loi irrecevable
sur le plan financier.
-La Constitution,
rien que la Constitution.
-La proposition ne sera donc pas
soumise au vote.
Cette décision
fait encore monter d'un cran
la tension dans l'hémicycle.
Protestations
-Vous nous avez empêchés
de voter !
Vous avez osé le faire !
Vous êtes devenus
complètement fous !
Applaudissements et acclamations
-Vous abîmez et écrabouillez
la démocratie parlementaire.
Vous oubliez surtout une chose,
la séparation
des pouvoirs.
-Fait rare, la présidente est
mise en cause personnellement.
-La présidente,
aux ordres de l'Elysée,
assume de ne pas être la garante
des droits du Parlement,
mais la misérable courroie
de transmission
d'un passage en force
ahurissant.
-Ce climat débouche
sur un nouveau débordement.
Protestations
-Monsieur Boyard...
Monsieur Boyard !
Je vous rappelle à l'ordre !
-Monsieur Boyard...
-Je prononce
un rappel à l'ordre
avec inscription
au procès-verbal.
-Sur l'ensemble
de l'année parlementaire,
91 sanctions ont été prononcées
contre des députés.
Un record et le signe d'un hémicycle
où le dialogue
devient parfois impossible.
-Mais tout le monde comprend
que l'Assemblée nationale
ne peut pas continuer
4 années supplémentaires comme cela.
C'est impossible.
Nous arrivons
à des stades d'autoritarisme
tellement forts,
que la question même
de savoir comment nous siégeons
dans l'Assemblée est posée.
-Après la réforme
des retraites,
on a démontré
qu'on pouvait continuer
à travailler à l'Assemblée,
à adopter des textes,
comme des projets de loi.
Ca veut dire que nos institutions,
elles ne sont pas bloquées.
Il n'y a pas
de crise institutionnelle.
Musique classique
-En 1 an,
le gouvernement a survécu
à 17 motions de censure,
une situation jamais vue
dans l'histoire
de la Ve République.
Jusqu'ici,
malgré la tempête parlementaire,
les projets de loi
du gouvernement
sont arrivés à bon port,
mais la traversée
est encore loin
d'être terminée.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA